[Musik]
in der engadiner bergwelt liegt das
hochalpine instituten
wir lernen und wohnen schüler von nah
und fern
schäfer aus sankt petersburg befindet
sich im letzten jahr des gymnasiums
schulkollegin batliner wohnt in spuren
und besucht die sportklasse
auch für robin aus der innerschweiz
stellen sich nun die weichen fürs leben
ein team von internetbetrügern kümmert
sich um die freuden und sorgen der
jugendlichen
und gerhard steuble amt als rektor des
traditionsreichen instituts
für alle ist es das jahr der
entscheidungen
[Musik]
in der küche des hochalpinen instituts
deutet nichts darauf hin dass es heute
für die abschluss klässler um die wurst
geht
es ist prüfungstag
küchenchef milliarden jahre hat es menü
bestehend aus fleisch und kartoffeln
nicht eigens für die maturanten so
zusammengestellt
wenn etwas nützlich ist für die prüfung
dann sind das früchte
fleisch ist eigentlich nicht besonders
gut um die leistung zu fördern aber es
steht hat auf dem speiseplan deshalb
gebe ich es ihnen
egal ob fleisch oder früchte was nicht
gelernt wurde kann auch nicht abgerufen
werden
auf die klasse 6 gewartet die
schriftliche matura prüfung im fach
deutsch auch für die bündnerin matla
dance und den internatsschüler robin fix
gilt es nun ernst
in der letzten folge der internatsschule
dann kam es am institut zu großen
veränderungen wegen unstimmigkeiten mit
dem verwaltungsrat srg rektor gerd
steuble konsequenzen
abschluss klässler seda puschkin verließ
die internatsschule hals über kopf
nachdem ihm nahegelegt wurde dass er ein
jahr repetieren sollen
unvergessliche momente dagegen für robin
pittis er traf auf dario cologna
kleiner gott ins absolvierte sogar ein
langlauftraining unter beobachtung des
doppel-olympiasiegers
der einst auch im stand zur schule ging
[Musik]
ganz oben im schulhaus unter dem dach
findet die maturaprüfung statt
guten morgen gut sie miteinander
wir starten jetzt mit deutsch es ist
immer angenehm soll jetzt macht director
es ist schön jetzt zum abschluss kommen
die schüler erhalten fragestellungen zu
zitaten und gedichten
hat robin das richtige gelernt
[Musik]
die prüfung dauert firma kleiner und
ihre klassenkollegen vier lange stunden
[Musik]
während die maturantinnen ihrer prüfung
schreiben haben auch jüngere schüler
aufgaben zu erledigen
internats mitarbeiterin ruth werner
wacht darüber
[Applaus]
verstoßen schüler gegen die hausordnung
müssen sie gemeinnützige arbeit leisten
solche dienste haben fast alle schon
einmal aufgebrummt bekommen auch die
maturanden dass einige ihrer schützlinge
das internat bald verlassen ist für roth
ballack kein grund zur wut
für die
zukunft vor
die nächste straße schumacher und das
ist das wohl ab
maturanden gehen junge schüler kommen
schon seit 100 jahren ist dass der lauf
der dinge im hochalpinen institut
[Musik]
immer mehr schüler beenden die prüfung
am ende bleiben nur noch mal kleiner und
robin übrig sie feilen bis zur letzten
sekunde an ihrer arbeit
[Musik]
beinahe und robin haben die schriftliche
matura nun hinter sich es fehlen noch
die mündlichen prüfungen
oben im bogen internet
der abtretende direktor gerhard steuble
zeigt seinem nachfolger das institut
gemacht und nach werken ist auch
angerichtet
nur bücher wurde vor kurzem vom
verwaltungsrat gewählt die möglichkeiten
dazu
eigentlich in absprache mit dem mit dem
internatsleiter aber nicht sein es ist
absolut im tv liebling
zeit also dass sich wohlfühlt schon mit
zur bild und zu hause heißt es dazu die
namen gemacht
möchte
der neue gesamtheit der bruno büchi ist
36 jahre alt und studierte
betriebswirtschaftler
einst aktiver kunstturner hat er sich
ein nach diplom in sportmanagement
angeeignet ebenso eines in
bildungspolitik tastatur um hervor ins
bild dass wir in diesem sensationellen
land kann stolz dass gott
das hat mein vorgänger gemacht ja
hans krankl
die straße hat die frau laufen und
konkreter wurde er hinter leerstand der
ganze artikel
zuletzt arbeitete bruno bücher in einer
kaderposition bei der migros klubschule
nachdem er in der erwachsenenbildung
tätig war übernimmt er nun eine schule
für jugendliche
ja sehr schön dass bei der
[Musik]
umgebung und damit das viel investiert
worden ist ein träumer sind gut das
letzte und sportinfrastruktur ja blöd
wenn franz teile und ja ich ja selber
auch wie aus dem sport und für mich ist
die kombination oder butter wird dass
schule und sport ist natürlich
hauptdurchschlag gewachsen was für mich
sehr interessant macht da mit dem label
swiss olympics koma da am hilfen und den
wechsel natürlich für mich dazu auch uns
kennenlernen von neue billig stufe das
sind die hauptgründe für für die
bewertung die starke persönliche
motivation des neuen gesamt leiters ist
entscheidend angesichts der anstehenden
herausforderungen
bruno bücher erhält zwar eine schöne
schule aber er wechselt auch in ein
schwieriges berufsumfeld
[Musik]
bevor robin sich auf die letzten
prüfungen vorbereitet hat er eine bitte
an internatsleiter jens bauer
robin möchte im zimmer seines ehemaligen
schulkollegen sewa puschkin nachschauen
ob nichts vergessen ging als dieser
überstürzt das internat verließ
gegen ende ließen sie das schulische
leistungen stark nach über die gründe
wird nach wie vor gerätselt
das ist
eine schule
es geht nicht um geschickt mails nach
hause
eigentlich da relativ wenig zurück mit
der abreise von sefa aus dem internat
ist auch der kontakt zu ihm abgebrochen
sankt petersburg ist nun wieder sewa
puschkins heimat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gemeinsam mit seinem freund ladig gc war
job die beiden kennen sich schon seit
dem kindergartenalter
[Musik]
plakativer auch hinten fast täglich
kontakt dieser hat ihm sogar bei matura
poster geholfen nun sind die beiden
besten freunde wieder vereint
bist du es genug
frischkäse
die familie puschkin wohnt in einem
noblen quartier in sankt petersburg
jetzt nach vier jahren die sewa im
internat war sieht mutter jana ihren
sohn wieder täglich am frühstückstisch
ich denke alles ist so gekommen wie es
kommen musste ich bin wirklich froh dass
er in der schweiz gelernt hat und ich
bin auch glücklich dass sie nach hause
zurückgekehrt ist
weg machen ist wirklich froh
mein vater schon
dass ich zurückgekommen bin und sie
denkt dass meine leistungen in der
schule waren schlecht auch weil ich hier
mein kopf wollte schon nach ostern
fordern dass eigentlich das scheiß nicht
für mich ein hallen landrat und ich
wollte irgendwie irgendwie in mir nach
russland zu fahren
[Musik]
zurück in der schweiz in felsberg merkur
hier wohnt die mutter von matt leider
gottes
es ist eine ereignisreiche zeit für die
20 jährige nicht nur wegen der matura
heute ist sie eingeladen zu einem
galadiner batliner wurde nominiert zur
wahl der bündner behindertensportlerin
des jahres
[Musik]
freundin hanna versucht die haare gemäß
der anleitung aus dem internet zu
therapieren
[Musik]
bei der auswahl der garderobe musste mit
leider nicht lange überlegen
[Musik]
die bündner sportnacht findet in chur
statt
kleiner wird gemeinsam mit ihrer mutter
hingehen
das hochalpine institut steht vor
wegweisenden monaten schließlich erhält
die schule eine neue leitung der
abtretende unter neue chef beenden die
hausführung
[Musik]
ist nadine ich weiß nicht ich buch nicht
zwingend einigen
sich auf
gerhard strate warten neue berufliche
herausforderungen vor vier monaten gab
es einen rücktritt als rektor bekannt
als reaktion auf die entlassung seiner
beiden prorektoren
über die gründe wollte sich der
verwaltungsrat nicht äußern doch zu
beginn der ganzen affäre dann eine
artikel serie in der größten bündner
tageszeitung welche das hochalpine
institut massiv kritisierte
dies alles geschah im winter schnee von
gestern
sexy und die halbe gemacht und ich habe
mich freiwillig entschieden
und du hast mit mitarbeitern eigentlich
nichts touren du hast
und jeden ausspruch dass du jetzt rasch
positiv von der belauschten darauf wann
hat ausrede widriger und das ist ja
nicht macht muss man jetzt nicht über
die
internationalste crew boni da an und
schauen sondern
machte schon wieder so willst du für
richtig finden schön dass du freilassen
oder gar nicht schlecht ja ich glaube
dass merkel das gespürt militärschule
die person jetzt getroffen hat ist eine
halle mit mit heute wie mit begeisterung
wie
experten verwaltungsrat und ja wir
merken es so süß wie schuhen und das für
mich wichtig dass eine vita mit ok und
auch aktiv genutzt um drei ecken und ich
das sehr positiv hat die aufgaben und
probiert aber aufwärts wird und gar
nicht mehr zur stütze auf das
vergangenen jahren nicht mit stoke city
und kenny floss khk zu machen
ein neubeginn wartet auf das hochalpine
institut doch bevor es soweit ist muss
das alte schuljahr erst einmal
abgeschlossen werden
noch stehen die mündlichen prüfungen an
internats mitarbeiterin ruth berger
kümmert sich um die maturanten die
morgen ihre letzten prüfungen haben
[Musik]
in dieser nacht da kann sich ruth berlau
sicher sein wird im internat niemand
etwas unerlaubtes anstellen
die größte
seit man auch wenn das messgerät
nicht
gut
[Musik]
vorfreude bei butt einer kadenz und
ihrer mutter justiz
in kohat die bündner sport macht
begonnen
[Musik]
die forscher aber die nach oben ich habe
wir haben die vom hersteller
zurückziehen so geben sport nicht allein
geht es da für ihn unterschreiben
sportlerin für fleißiges zeichnet
weniger steht ist zu setzen und die
russen müssen deutsch das gymnasium das
ist mitglied des peter das ist
olympische kies und schweizer meister es
laden
die 20 jährige mann sei allerdings
ausgereiften sportarten stehen und
langlauf gespielt ist die mehrfache
schweizer meisterin die meisterschaft
[Musik]
behindertensportlerin des jahres 2004
sind ist spannung scheint wieder spielt
für matt leider hat es leider nicht ganz
gereicht
[Applaus]
da hätte ich aber
handelt ob ich noch sagen ein signal für
sie
sich hin zu spuren
aber vor der maturafeier muss man
kleiner noch die mündlichen prüfungen
hinter sich bringen
[Musik]
die einen gehen die prüfungen eher
spielerisch an robin dagegen ist am
büfett morgen stehen für ihn nicht nur
die letzten examen an sondern er wird
auch das internat für immer verlassen
die dreifache und mona und denken das
fertige ständig geschehen
also ein ums andere sagen
während im unterengadin die köpfe
rauchen wird in sankt petersburg
gefeiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leverkusen ist mit freunden beim billard
spiel
[Musik]
wäre das letzte schuljahr anders
verlaufen dann wäre auch sie war jetzt
im prüfungsstress
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass ich das alles schaffen
sie machen das und ich mache
[Musik]
endlich ist er da der
allerletzte prüfungstag für die
abschluss chrysler
[Musik]
im internet büro schaut ruth becker
danach welcher schüler wand zur
mündlichen prüfung muss
die nacht verlief wie erwartet
dass
minister wirklich dass sie ist im griff
mit dem brief als thema die server macht
ich weg dachte aber überhaupt neustart
und sagen 15
verschlafen haben
damit ist
robbie nennt bis zur letzten sekunde für
die mündliche deutsch matura als
bochumer klinik lasst uns das nicht tun
und das jetzt als einzige vorher
angeschaut das genau das buch und
[Musik]
dem hier nie beliebt nach filmt
die vorangehen der prüfung ist noch im
gange
jetzt aber schnell zu sein
batliner ist in derselben prüfungs
gruppe wie robin und jeweils vor ihm an
der reihe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die mündlichen examen dauern eine
viertelstunde
[Musik]
trotzdem blicken
und ich glaube 26 im anschluss ab 78
[Musik]
robbie nähert sich seinem reifezeugnis
schritt für schritt
[Musik]
in der 5 millionen metropole sankt
petersburg beschäftigt sich der waldsee
mappus kinder mit wie er ohne schweizer
schulabschluss seine zukunft gestaltet
er besucht die universität für
elektrotechnik an der er ein studium
beginnen will
mutter und sohn werden von zwei
mitarbeitern der universität durch den
campus geführt
jeder kann hier studieren da er auf der
basis seines russischen schulabschlusses
die notwendigen prüfungen erfolgreich
absolviert hat für die eth in zürich wo
sie war einst studieren wollte würde das
zwar nicht reichen aber in russland ist
das ausbildungssystem anders
strukturiert
hier ist die bibliothek und dort alles
ab
[Musik]
ja ich komme dann die am studienende
dann
bin ich hier noch viele jahre am
studieren und nachher wenn ich nach
deutschland war für zwei jahre studierte
und dann dann und dann schauen wir mal
mein traum ist mein business zu machen
in seiner heimat hat sie war seine
zuversicht zurück gewonnen auch träume
haben wieder platz sein herz scheint
wieder dort zu sein wo es hingehört
[Musik]
das konto der ofen
dann kommt nicht überall da der stars
der
dank an gott und
stellt auf und nach erwartet alle da
mein zweiter
klasse machen
und dann versteckt
uhr gerhard steuble testet zusammen mit
im haushalt die abläufe für die
maturafeier sie wird noch am selben
abend durchgeführt gleich nach den
letzten mündlichen prüfungen
es ist die sechste maturafeier die
steuer als rektor miterlebt doch dieses
mal verbindet ihn mehr mit den
maturanten als sonst ebenso wie die
abschlussklasse steht auch der
61-jährige steuble vor einem neuanfang
bis ganz neues anfangen und jetzt machen
in ihrer firma auf und
das ist vier mal wo einerseits
projekt im geltungsbereich pädagogische
konzept für irgendwelchen
aufgestellt und gleichzeitig aber auch
so verstanden dass das pädagogische
konzept dafür einzelpersonen
laufbahnberatung
so ganz eigentlich wieder auswetzen
gemachten auch nur jetzt als auftrag an
ideal gefährden
seit 33 jahren arbeitet als pädagoge
seine breite erfahrung wieder nun
anbieten zur unterstützung von
institutionen oder von eltern die nicht
mehr weiter wissen
[Musik]
nur noch eine prüfung für robin pic ist
spanisch mündlich
[Musik]
was will ist das buch sex ja was das
thema
[Musik]
ja sie ist am anfang nur werte und am
ende voll
na
das geht ja kommen
doch das apple
[Musik]
auch wenn rundherum alle nervös werden
roth barriere lässt sich nicht davon
anstecken
sie kommt von einem einkauf zurück
[Musik]
und machte das tradition dass sie
bekommen
am letzten prüfungstag sind mehr
internats mitarbeiter als üblich
anwesend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
batliner hat die spanisch prüfung hinter
sich
ende matura
gleich nach batliner folgt robin
[Musik]
die spanischlehrerin wartet bereits
eur besser als man denkt und was
schlecht begangen hatte
also ist
[Musik]
jetzt ist es auch für robin endgültig
vorbei
matura bestanden
doppeltes pech also ich weiß dass sie
der standard hofft dass hier
die notorische
[Musik]
langsamen sätze aber die machen hier ja
denn
professional
[Musik]
plattform ist
rektor gerhard steuble geht nochmals die
musik durch die er an der heutigen feier
abspielen will
das ist
einfach der markeninhaber die situation
genießen
sie mit irgendwas anderes
verhalten zeige jetzt wird die größte
show
[Musik]
der sonder gefühl aber ich habe es
geschafft
und jetzt bin ich frei und so frei wie
nach der motorisch endlich mehr wenn man
muss nicht mehr lange machen jetzt die
pfarrerinnen und
über dich nur nach sich selber
verantwortlich
wir freuen uns darauf eng zu machen
oben im vierten stock werden die zimmer
bereits geräumt
[Musik]
auf robin packt seine siebensachen schon
dieser nacht wird er nicht mehr hier im
internat schlafen
[Musik]
1000 auf dem raucher platz braucht es
ein wenig mehr als üblich
[Musik]
sicher ist sicher gut berliner will die
situation unter kontrolle haben
wir fangen auch für jede
weitere international weiter kommen um
den maturanten zu gratulieren
[Musik]
unten in spuren im hause gottes geht es
ruhiger zu viel erholungszeit gönnt sich
mal kleiner aber nicht gerade mal ein
wochenende nach
dem sommer will sie dann an die
pädagogische hochschule in chur
[Musik]
einen stock tiefer erwartet man kleines
vater
egal ob wechsel sei
[Musik]
zehn minuten vor dem termin für das
matura foto ist matt lauer endlich parat
wobei die schuhe hat sie noch nicht
angezogen und sie muss noch den berg
hinauf zum hochalpinen institut
[Applaus]
letzte vorbereitungen auch im internet
büro
ich machte mich willkommen das marshall
brauchen einfach modeln
dafür ist diplom
hier sehe ich nicht so
da wird sich schluss vom jahr
zu werden
in wenigen minuten ist der termin für
das foto der maturaklasse
im moment mal ich habe sie jetzt
kommunizieren sie mal richtig zu
was machst du wenn
der job hopping
was heißt oberen knopf macht
könnte man wie in st
[Musik]
in der eingangshalle versammeln sich
mehr und mehr angehörige doch robin
wieder raus zu seinen schulkollegen
nein
so gut angezogen war die klasse 6g noch
nie
nun stellen sie sich auf für das
abschlussfoto
auch mal einer schafft es gerade noch
rechtzeitig aufs bild
[Musik]
für einen kurzen moment steht die zeit
stehen
und wenn mal einer kadenz und robin
pittis viele jahre später dieses foto
wieder in die hand nehmen werden sie
sich zurück erinnern an ihre
klassenkollegen ihre lehrer ihren rektor
und dann das so wunderschön gelegene
hochalpine institute an
[Musik]